all right before we get our racing game
adaptation on we need to get our racing
game brain fuel along which brings me to
the sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by factor factor offers
fresh never frozen meals and a variety
of options right to your door with 34
plus Chef prepared dietitian approved
weekly options there's always something
new to try keto calorie smart vegetarian
vegan options Protein Plus whatever your
flavor they got you covered no prep No
Mess ready in two minutes so you can get
to eating while you're binging or gaming
which is great for me I do enjoy eating
also my body requires it but as I've
said before in terms of General
enjoyment and fun factor I put grocery
shopping around the same level as being
in a movie theater in which people are
using their phones it's just not my
thing so Factor delivered fresh right to
my door in the fighting game world we
call that perfect so go to factor75.com
or click the link below and use promo
code John's 50 to get yourself 50 off
your first Factor box and now that
PlayStation's car Carnage got an
adaptation well PlayStation's car racing
also has what a summer
[Music]
all right so Gran Turismo is directed by
Neil blomkamp who's been hit or miss
with me but the fact remains he did
District 9. I'll always look forward to
a new movie by him but it's also based
on the true story of yan martinborough
who is a gamer played a lot of Gran
Turismo he was so good at Gran Turismo
he got invited to have his shot at
actually being a race car driver so one
of my tricks to uh see how to pronounce
someone's name is to find an interview
with them in which they say their name
or someone says their name in front of
them and they're not corrected swore I
found one
but I but I can't find it again so
Archie matakaway plays Yan martinborough
I thought he was great very he's
relatable our fellow gamer nerds whose
parents are like you need a plan I'm
like this isn't a plan
also he wasn't an arrogant gamer during
the trailer it was like is he is he
arrogant gamer nerd he kind of comes
across that way probably Rory I would
dust him in a lot no that line I don't
even remember being in the movie and he
wasn't he was you know he was just a
young dude who wanted his shot David
Harbor was great in the movie what you
see is what you get with David Harbor if
you liked what you saw on the trailer
with David Harbor if you had that
feeling of
does he know he's being filmed I still
can't answer that and that's kind of
what makes it amazing you puked on my
lawn he's the one who's gonna take these
gamer nerds and through trial by fire
gonna see if they got what it takes to
race but it's not just that it's the
bond between his character and the main
character throughout the film that's
growing this friendship between the two
of them because when they first meet I
don't know they just don't seem like
friends as time goes on it's like hey
maybe there's something there with this
kid and you know he's pretty much the
only one in the industry being nice to
him they showed that in the trailer in
fact as I'm spilling it out I'm like wow
that trailer did just kind of give you
the breakdown of the entire film point
is it was nice to see the two of them
have great chemistry together and it was
a big part of the heart of the movie
also the movie looks great it's shocked
to be intense when you're supposed to be
biting your nails during the racing
scenes biting my nails I was gonna feel
like Neil blomkamp was like all right
Target demographic target audience
Gamers let's face it video games do it
in more grandiose fashion than movies do
just
video games are intense man it's like
Neil blomkamp knew that he was like
Gamers have seen some [__] they've seen
some intense stuff we have to make this
movie feel intense and that Parts it did
but that's where we run into some of the
mixed bag this movie is at times
although some scenes felt intense some
races also felt kind of rushed when I'm
watching a race in the movie I like it
when a movie makes it feel like I am
there in the race and I'm there for the
Long Haul but when the training of these
gamer nerds hooked me and I was like all
right I'm in a movie built around
training that's essentially Top Gun Top
Gun on Wheels let's go wow it's over
that was like 15 minutes so to speedrun
you to the end of this movie where it
does give you that fulfilling feeling of
okay I'm in the race with the main
character and we are there and it looks
gorgeous I'm biting my nails again felt
like it Montage through the other races
leading up to it or just showed you the
end score card I get it those were quite
a few races so you don't want the movie
to feel repetitive but it did feel like
it was a mini series that was condensed
to feature film length so like the movie
flows and Ebbs it starts out interesting
and then montages through a bunch of
stuff and then it's interesting again
has some moments of heart absolutely in
there I do wish his dad was in the movie
more better phrase I wish Jaime and
hansu was better utilized in the film
accomplished actor jimin hansu plays his
father and there is a nice moment
between him and his son because you know
it's the story of the dad being like do
something with your life I don't
understand why you just sit and play
video games all the time then this big
shot and right so there's a good moment
of heart in there but there was no real
lead up to it I felt like the real
father-son Dynamic was between the main
character and David Harbor's character
rather than the main character and his
father but the important thing is I was
getting the Feels by the end of the
movie it is an Underdog Story it's
absolutely what you think the movie is
going to be it's pretty predictable
because because it's an Underdog Story
with the premise that it has some of the
other stylistic choices beyond the
racing feeling fast and intense like the
racing to its core just feels like
really intense racing but there are
other stylistic choices that do throw
back to the game you know when he's
racing you start seeing the track like
the game it's got to be a tough balance
to strike you know connect with the
people who know the game and give them
the visuals that do call back to that
but you don't want their friends to be
lost you want their friends to watch it
be like I don't even why does this even
happening I don't even know what the
[__] but fun energetic and even
inspiring at the end absolutely it
doesn't break new storytelling ground
but it doesn't have to I found it to be
a good time no alcohol or quiet it is
kind of funny to me even a little ironic
there is this cool fight the man kind of
energy going on in this movie you know
the people's champ fight those corporate
douchebags you know the type those
soulless bastards the kind of douchiness
that makes people make a video game in
which you grind away with such little
in-game currency payout in contrast to
the really expensive cars you really
want the whole thing's just built around
inspiring or provoking the gamer to
actually spend real money to buy fake
cars and oh wait no that's Gran Turismo
7. hope they know it's about them too
all right so Gran Turismo was supposed
to come out this weekend got pushed back
two weeks but embargo lifts when embargo
lifts or you're getting this one a
little early regardless Gran Turismo
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's your favorite Gran
Turismo game whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]